welcome back to las vegas now may is
national foster care month
helping ensure children in foster care
have what they need to feel healthy
safe and especially loved one company
i'm excited to introduce you to makes
this their mission every single day
so let's welcome courtney acuna to the
show owner and founder of this belongs
to hey courtney
hi thank you so much for having me oh
i'm so excited a little background
i saw you on instagram fell in love with
your clothes and your bags and then
realized
the message behind it all was even more
dope so tell us what belongs this
belongs to means
so i was so oblivious to this issue
that is across the nation first of all i
was so
uneducated on foster care in general
much less the fact that foster care
kids move from home to home in trash
bags most of the time
and so i didn't believe it i did so much
research and it's true i mean
so many kids move in trash bags and so
i wanted to create a product that would
provide
a solution to that problem and so i
started this belongs to
it's a one-for-one business bottle when
you buy our lux
weekender will donate a huge duffel bag
to a child in foster care
and they get the they get to write their
name
on that line um and so they have a bag
to call their own
and to move all their things to and it's
just
we're just trying to be a help in the
big problem that is so incredible i love
that concept and i think
one of the main reasons is to give these
kids ownership right what does that mean
exactly so many people even when i
launched it because we launched on
kickstarter we had a great response but
even when i launched it
i was a little bit unsure of how big of
a problem is this really and we had
tons of people probably over 100 people
message me and say
i was that kid i was that kid that moved
from home to home
with my stuff in a trash bag or grocery
bags and i just want to say thank you
for doing this so that a new generation
coming through
hopefully won't have that problem like i
did i was astonished i had no clue that
this was such a
such an issue wow and this is coming
straight from your heart so how can
people actually help you support or help
you support these kids
and shop your line so like i said it's
one for one so if you buy our bag we're
actually gonna donate
a bag through an organization called
national angels
they are a nationwide organization they
have chapters all over the country and
they
really help equip foster care not just
the children but the families and so
they're giving us an inside look on to
helping you know be the solution and so
just buy a bag if you buy a bag we're
going to donate one i love it and of
course as i told you i was looking
through your products myself and i saw
clothing i saw bags so what all that can
we shop
actually on the website so we have we
have
cute crop tops that are in we have
hoodies we have some caps
i have actually some toiletry bags that
are coming out that are coming out
really soon that aren't even on the site
yet
we have more product coming but we have
you know our big weekenders like our
main our main product but the merch the
clothes are so fun to sport it's such a
conversation starter people will stop me
and they'll be like
what does your shirt mean what is this
belongs to mean so it's definitely a
great way to spread awareness
i'm excited i'm definitely going
shopping at the website i want the crop
top
that's the one i saw with the crop top
with the hoodie the bag everything so
thank you so much courtney we really
appreciate everything you're doing
for kids all around the world i could
say thank you so much for having me i
really appreciate it
all right jc i'll send it over to you